[Music]
thank you so much and thank you logos
for having us all here we're all
involved in popup City pop-up Village
space in different ways so we're excited
to talk with you I think even though we
got a little bit of an introduction um I
would love to start with everybody just
giving an introduction for ourselves and
then our popup City experience our Pro
tour would you like to start yeah I
would love to hey everyone I'm teore I'm
one of the founders of edge City we have
been doing the papa Village thing for
the last year and a half or so uh we
came out of the zalu ecosystem like a
lot of things did I'm sure we'll touch
on that we create Villages that are very
U multidisiplinary they focus on the
multigenerational aspect so we try and
bring families kids we make it a very uh
default healthy environment and we
usually have between 500 to 1,000 people
pass through the doors over the course
of about a month or um four to 6 weeks
is roughly our format um for me this is
a very just exciting step on the way to
some of the ideas that were talking
about in in this parallel Society space
so yeah excited to get into
it hello everyone this is Audrey and
also the initiator of shangai Wu and for
shangai Wu uh actually it's a second
year for shahai will organize the first
shahai last August in man China and for
shahai it's uh we just organize the
second Shah in chimi and it last for
about six weeks and for sh is more like
the Gateway for people to unboard the
web stre we want that the general people
could understand what is crypto value
and help them establish a long-term
Vision in crypto area which is very
important and uh uh for the last of we
just end the sh yesterday and you can
see we also have the nebas from chimi to
Bangkok which is fantastic and lots of
Shah members and also from a city lots
of members uh come to Bangkok today and
I hope every of you could see them on
different
conference hello my name is Eva Claus
I'm one of the co-organizers of zenzal
we just had a a presentation not too
long ago um our goal is really to
catalyze a a growth ecosystem in
Zanzibar which is a seni autonomous
island off the coast of
Tanzania uh focused on Talent
cultivation uh governance
experimentation and cultural cultural
change thank you for having
us and I'm Veronica I co-initiated the
Zu Village Georgia experiment in the
country of Georgia this summer which was
an attempt at having another iteration
of the Zulu experiment with
cross-pollination of different
Industries permissionless schedule Etc
but a greater focus and vision with
cyppher Punk ethos truth seeking
defensive accelerationism techno
optimism and especially cognitive
sovereignty because we believe that any
Collective effort let alone a parallel
Society is going to become dysfunctional
if individual cognitive sovereignty is
not um prioritized and then I'm also now
leading operations for zuu do city which
is the community collaboration platform
with ethereum ecosystem applications
supporting the Zulu movement and this
wasn't intended to be the next question
because a number of us have talked about
Zulu in different way shaped or form I'm
curious how many people in the audience
have heard of zulu does this mean
anything oh wow okay so the vast
majority I guess if you're not familiar
with it you can ask anyone around to you
but what I'm curious then for everyone
is what is the connection with Zulu how
did Zulu in Inspire or lead to your
involvement with this
space yeah so for me Zulu was a very
singular um meaningful experience
personally I feel like
it um it it was an environment where I
felt like many sides of my personality
were able to express themselves and it
felt just really good in that regard I
came I organized the AI track there and
then I kind of got involved in more of
the organization and eventually few
months later um was a core organizer of
zuc connect which was kind of the second
big event that we did with that
community and uh pretty much out of that
I got pilled on the whole pop-up city
concept I feel like Zulu as an event
really expanded the adjacent possible
for lots of people a lot of people who
came realized that this was possible and
actually something interesting to do and
in that regard I really feel like it
kind of kicked of this whole
movement yeah I I think uh Shah will may
be the first
inspir the PO City inspired by sh by
Zulu after zalu uh we organized the
first Shanghai wi last August and what
is very important is that we got before
we organizing shahai War I think uh we
prepar it uh at about last June and we
got a lot of advice from the zal team
which is Nico J and also lots of them
give us a very good advice for B on for
how to organize the
community how to help people get know
each other and lots of
experience also including something
about the aration something like that
that's why I think uh for lots of people
who want to organize or start their own
pup City the knowledge sharing is very
important you could learn a lot of SC
and notot of lot of experience from the
people who have organized the PO cities
and it's and more important thing that
we need more open access for everyone to
get to know the experience how to
organize their own public
cities so I did not attend uh zalu and I
attended zuc connect very briefly for a
couple days um but even in in the short
spent of time that I spent there it was
it was very obvious that there were some
uh there was a symbiosis with what we
were trying to do in fumba town which is
a new city located in the special
economic zone it had also kind of become
this emerging chilling point for digital
Nomads around Zanzibar it's one of the
few places that has a reliable backup
electricity generator so you have
internet you have electricity there so
people kind of gravitated towards there
and because it's a new city it's it's
really in need of community cultivation
so Zulu and kind of the values
instantiated there and and zuc connect
and what all of us are trying to do in
our own pop-up cities now um really
graphs well onto that new city model
that that needs people to come in and
kind of catalyze more growth catalyze
community and uh launch the new city
onto a new trajectory uh so that's
that's kind of the the inspiration for Z
zanzu in fumba town and kind of bringing
those Zulu Builder Community Values to
uh animate a new
city thank you guys so I'd love to for
all of us to describe a bit further the
vision for the projects that we ran or
currently ranning or planning to run um
and because this is a panel for maybe
all of you or potentially going to
organize your own popup Village or
something along these lines maybe we
could focus on what was the target group
and then how did you attract um that
specific Target group were there any
compromises that you or trade that you
could not make or could or needed to
make based off of that Vision um and
especially how does it affect Logistics
so what you're trying to do then
operationally what did you have to
navigate for it and we can keep going in
order or anyone can
start yeah so for zenzu one our our
Focus uh was local engagement we wanted
to be uh the very best pop-up City doing
local engagement and uh especially in in
Zanzibar so we targeted universities
that some of the first people that that
we spoke with were uh the professors in
the computer science department at the
State University of Zanzibar and then
Noah I'm sure most of you know Noah also
uh ran Communications and and
Partnerships with some universities in D
Salam so we got a bunch of students
coming over for student weekend but we
also met with other stakeholders in the
local startup ecosystem so Cube Zanzibar
is the only accelerator on the island
and we uh co-hosted an event with them
we also got some accelerators from D
Salam to come and contribute to Startup
weekends so we got uh Sahara Adventures
we're very proud nective Richards is is
an incredible uh figure in the in the
local Tanzania scene she now going to
kagali anyway um so making sure that we
are focusing on local groups who are
already doing incredible work and giving
them more of a platform uh to use zanz
Alo to kind of bolster their own work
that they're doing year round that
they've spent you know years developing
and making sure that zenzal is very
aligned with where the local community
uh wants to go and what they're
interested in and and you know you asked
about uh you know what are some what are
some compromises so being in a new city
right a lot of our budget initially went
to event setup so creating the main
event space Furnishing a co-working
space um and this year to kind of stay
more true to our uh focus on local
engagement we want to spend more time
and more of our resources uh funding
local Builders and bringing more people
from around East Africa to to zanbar to
contribute to zanzu so you know as as
the years go by and we kind of host this
event multiple times you you pick up
those lessons you kind of hone your
goals uh and so that's something that
we're thinking a lot about for for this
year is how we can improve on last year
kind of double down on our target
audience and uh now that we have that
basic infrastructure build
focusing on getting getting the right
people in the
door yeah actually uh same as zalu and
Sh is more focusing on the local
community and you know for the we start
from the chain speaking community and
last year is organized in mland China
and lots of the developers and lots of
the members came from the Chinese
speaking community and for this year
though we are in chimi but I think still
60% of the commun members from chin
speaking community and for sh we more
wanted because I think uh nay is very
important is that we need to engage more
local members in the whole crypto area
yeah that's why each country each region
have their own very specific culture and
if we want the crypto things go Global
and we need to combine different culture
together and to help people get to know
each other and you know for Asian area
there is a very long-term traditional
culture that's why we want to bring the
tradition wisdom with the technology
together that's why most of them are
from chain speaking community and also
from the Asia uh communities yeah and
for this year I think uh you know for
after last year we organized it in last
August and after last year of Shang lots
of the community Shang community members
join the follow up popups no matter the
mo mind the zoo connect and also lot of
the mo to Ed City and that's why for
this year the way organizing in the CH
my it's more become the bridge for to
connect people from the local W Global
to help them to get understand the which
each other and Community with each other
this make a incable impact for the whole
community and to because you know
sometimes the Asia people off shy they
don't yeah they don't just speak l so we
want to give them the platform to show
themselves yeah really cool um okay so
just to touch on the vision and maybe
I'll separate the logistics because I I
don't want to talk too long but just
like Visions Vision wise what is the
point of all of these popup villages in
the first place and I think I really see
them as kind of like the Proto or like
the early versions of um you know some
people call them like Cloud Nations
Network societies um parallel societies
and I think these are critical aspects
to bootstrap the things that we need in
order to create those those institutions
and those entities that I think will be
very impactful over the next couple of
decades and so in service of that Vision
what we're thinking about at Edge city
is we don't necessarily feel like we yet
have the right answer of what that
should look like but we want to create
the space where those answers will
percolate up so it's a very um it's a
very Bottoms Up theory of change it's
very you know let's let's see let a
thousand flowers bloom and let's see
what happens so when we think about
doing that that's why we um we want to
do multiple of these big events per year
we really like this monthlong format
because it's long enough that people
take it seriously but it doesn't have
the pressure of permanence
right so we work in partnership with new
city projects but those projects have to
make permanent decisions for how they're
going to structure themselves we are
much more flexible we can have people
come they can experiment with new ways
of living new technologies and then it's
fine if it doesn't work out we can try
it again the next time so that's how we
think about it at a high level and then
the next level is okay what is the
experience we want to create for people
in order to facilitate that level of
experimentation that could actually have
societal implications down the line we
think of four main pillars or four main
principles um need to figure out the
terminology of the experience we want it
to be uh we want to focus on health and
well-being so that people feel their
best selves when they're there and make
it just super easy for that to happen um
we focus on co-creation so people are
very engaged in the act of creating the
thing it's not very centralized we just
set up the infrastructure and then let
people actually you know uh color in the
edges um it's multidisiplinary
so we came out of the crypto space we
are very crypto we're very ethereum
aligned to be more specific but we also
think it's important to bridge outside
of just this space and to bring the tech
that we're developing within the
blockchain space to AI to biotech to you
know Phil let's bring philosophers let's
bring artists let's bring musicians so
that's a core aspect of everything we do
and the fourth one is multigenerational
which I mentioned but you know if we're
building the Future Let's actually have
the kids around that are going to
inherit it completely changes the vibe
completely changes the way that people
act um and we've had some incredible
families uh some of whom are actually in
the audience so hey um so yeah so that's
kind of the the like the Mission Vision
and then kind of the core strategy and I
can touch on the um things that we had
to um
some how did you frame it more like the
logistics the logistics yeah so um this
is really hard to do we've had a lot of
it takes a lot of work uh to house you
know 300 people at the same time a
thousand people over the course of the
month to actually have them in an
environment that feels good for everyone
where people can you know uh have a good
experience coordinate with each other
Etc it is almost possible to find the
right space for this so we've had to
we've had to try a lot of different
things zalu was in a resort which was
interesting some aspects of that were
amazing some there were some drawbacks
um zuuk connect was in the middle of
Istanbul it was like one big co-working
space in about 20 hotels where people
stayed um Edge Esmeralda which we did in
California was in a 20,000 person town
called hburg beautiful but like
relatively spread out I think that
actually approximates as close to almost
perfect as as as as at least we've
gotten um changai was similar to that we
had about 10 venues all within a
10-minute walk so those are some of the
logistics but there isn't existing
infrastructure that is perfect for this
kind of thing so we kind of have to you
know duct tape it together in in a bunch
of different ways I'm sure everyone's
had that experience yeah I want to add
one thing more about that because you
know for last year I have wasted also in
a skate result that's why all
people three col meter there was nothing
and no vage so that's why all the
members just stay in the same scale
result that's why in the dinner time of
the lunch time you could see all the
people around that's why lots of them
have a strong bonding with each other
but since different in this year chai
because you know we have lots of popup
sties here and people just try have in
visit different popup cities it's very
interesting because it's very different
and very unique things happen in chimi
because lots of different people from
different regions Community with each
other is also very interesting we could
see a lots of chemistry in that area but
it's a different uh aspect but I think
both of these different kinds of tabs
also make a very important significant
area in the POA
cities yeah 100% I think what happened
in changm the last month was very
interesting kind of at a meta level of
this exploration where it wasn't just
one or two there was about 10
experiments running concurrently and
everyone was kind of going between them
and learning from each other so that
archipelago model was also very
interesting um but yeah the last thing
I'll say on the difficulty side aside
from just the general infrastructure is
that in order to make things the way you
want them um it can be very difficult
especially because we're very
opinionated and principled around the
family side and the health side um it is
very hard to make infrastructure for you
know 50 kids to be there especially of
very different ranges they have very
different experiences of the world so
that's definitely something that we're
working on more and I think over time
we're going to ref find it um last thing
I'll say there is that one thing we're
seeing is that going back to a place is
so much easier than continuing to do new
places so we will keep going around the
world we think it's very important to go
to new locations let other people
experience this kind of thing but I
could imagine us over time and some of
the other projects continuing to go back
to certain areas the way we're about to
do in California next here because you
know it you've developed the
relationships you can invest you know
we're now helping to build a permanent
new city there so yeah I think things
like that are The Logical
conclusion thank you and yeah I want to
ask next about some of the repeated
organizational aspects that both of you
have experienced and you're gearing up
to do um and also to emphasize Timo and
Audrey are talking about the this
location distinction I think if you
thinking of if you want to start your
own pop-up Village I would say the first
decision you need to make is are you
going to organize accommodation for the
participants um and maybe this second
one that's related are you going to be
in a city or are you going to be Rural
and isolated and both of those variables
heavily impact the logistics if you're
trying to organize accommodation for
multiple hundreds of people for a very
long time you're going to have a lot
more lift than if you just need to it's
not adjust it's still coordinating but
if you just just need to find a central
building that people are going to be
coming to but you let everybody
self-organize housing um which is easier
in a city if you're Ral there's the
transportation so that's the first
decision um some of the first decisions
to make and I'll just answer the
question as well from the Zu Village
Georgia perspective part of our vision
um as I mentioned we wanted to be as
Cipher punk as possible it was something
that we felt at the original Zulu but we
wanted to actually emphasize it in
practice and that did come with
tradeoffs where we did very little
advertising we just posted on less wrong
um and then of course we did share a bit
on social media we didn't tell anybody
where it was going to be we also
wouldn't share who was going to be there
which limited we even um the on the
budget side of things there were
sponsors that pulled out because we
couldn't confirm if so and so people
would be there um and also people that
wanted to attend but then they asked oh
is this person going to be it limited a
a little bit of it I think it was worth
it um for the quality of things but it
also led to as we were talking about
bootstrapping where you're a single
person that's then trying to do all the
things I'm still editing the videos from
the summer and getting those slowly but
surely on YouTube so when you decide the
vision then there's going to be these
Downstream effects that do affect
Logistics as well so now I want to um
pick your guys' brains a little bit
you're gearing up to I think go to the
same place right so exactly what they're
um what they were touching upon you're
going to go back to California um but
also team I want to start by picking on
you because you've organized so many of
them I'm really curious how has your
thinking changed what has what have you
learned and what are you doing
differently now as you organize your
next one compared to zoo connect the
very first
one um yeah I
mean how has our thinking changed we're
just getting better and better at this I
think there's there's like a startup
idea of Stay Alive until you get good
and that's kind of a core early stage
startup Max and I feel the same thing
here where you just have to stay in the
game and like do it a few times we were
talking backstage just before this about
how uh like there's a feeling of burnout
that happens after these things usually
we've seen it a lot people come in with
a lot of excitement and then it's it's
such intense work so many things happen
that you can't expect and you just burn
out hard and I was reflecting after that
and thinking like wow I actually feel
amazing right now which is strange it's
actually very different to this time
last year off zuc Connect where I needed
like two weeks to just clear my head
right now I feel more energized and more
excited
so I think the lesson there is just a
secret I don't know I mean I think
having an amazing team obviously helps
we've done this a few times everyone
kind of knows their Lane we're slowly
building the team and we know exactly
where we need to slop people in and we
know exactly what kind of person to uh
find one thing if if you guys do your
own you'll realize very quickly you can
um you instantly know whether the person
you're considering to bring onto the
team usually they start as a volunteer
or something you can just see every side
of them because you're kind of you're
all living in the same vicinity you know
so um that's been I guess the main
learning it's nothing crazy
groundbreaking it's like find the right
people you want to do it with and just
go for it you know yeah that's that's
what I was going to say that the team is
so important and I think one of the the
good things about being able to go back
to the same place is you know last year
it was not really legible like what is
this pop-up City coming to Zanzibar what
are you guys going to do and we were
kind of you know we want to do XYZ but
we didn't have a very clear plan uh you
know a couple months out which makes it
difficult to uh you know market and and
get more people on board but after the
first event now we have a whole lot of
uh local organizers who are very excited
to contribute when we go back so we have
three more core organizers that will
participate that uh all live in in
Zanzibar in fumba town so going back
being able to pick up those
relationships strengthen those
Partnerships have people that are on the
ground all year long that can keep those
relationships warm and and host maybe
smaller events throughout the year uh
makes it much easier logistically but
also from a programming from uh an
engagement uh perspective uh getting the
right team getting a a locally grounded
team uh and bringing eager people into
the ecosystem and encouraging them to
co-create as as the years go by because
then you just accumulate more and more
people that are that are excited to
contribute actually I want to ask a
quick question about that for the C team
uh are they mainly part 10 or the four
we have five uh sorry six full-time
people and that probably grows to
about um 10 to 12 in terms of our team
uh in with volunteers during the event
and then depending on the structure
there's probably another 10 to 15 with
our local partner so the way we
structure it is that we when we Scout
for locations we're scouting just as
much for the people that we want to work
with as the place so for example in
Thailand we met an incredible local team
and I think if we hadn't done that we
probably wouldn't have done the thing um
and it helps with everything right up
and down the stack a key part of it is
just local integration they know
everyone they brought in the mayor the
governor's office and um at at the scale
that we wanted to do it those are just
conversations we had to have and then um
local Builders and everything thing but
they also just know the space obviously
so yeah that's the structure of our team
five fulltime probably five more kind of
Co volunteers on our end and then
between 10 and 15 local
Partners ours was entirely volunteer uh
so actually last year some of the core
organizers paid to attend zanzo um we
are making it free for all zores all
tanzanians and we're hoping to make the
entire event free this year but we have
no plan plans or budget to hire
full-time staff so we're still operating
volunteer this
year and you know for most of our uh
part and that's why we are trying to
figure a way to make them sustainable
because we can just if you all of the
part there also cause lots of problem
during the organizing of cities but if
we want to hear our find some for and
co- computers and we collaborate
together to make sure we need to find
figure out way to make it sustainable no
matter it's financial problem or yeah
lots of problem need to
solve yeah kind of piggybacking off of
that maybe we could talk a bit about
Finance or funding what the different
approaches are I think we all may have
various approaches there and of course
it's a been a big Topic in um I would
say in the zuu movement and overlapping
communities within it of how can pop up
cities how can you start a village and
make it sustainable not be reliant on
just sponsors or donations does anyone
want to
start we're trying to diversify our our
funding sources last year so the
quadratic funding round was our our main
source last year and then we got a grant
from uh the charter cities Institute
which is an NGO and then uh another I
think our total budget was about 30
5,000 and and most of that went to event
space and uh co-working space and then
the rest was uh breakfast and and
scholarship housing um this year because
you know we've expanded our organizing
team we have one member that's very
excited to organize an entrepreneurship
week so looking at uh multilateral
development Banks so World Bank has
funded Tunisia ecosystem week uh there's
the the embassy at the Netherlands in in
zanbar that funds a lot of work like
that and some local banks so we're
trying to raise local funding um maybe
some from from development institutions
and then also things like the quadratic
funding around which I think most of us
has have probably participated in
um yeah that's that's kind of our plans
for this year and then we are thinking
about longer term plans uh maybe you
know funding some sort of community
center that we can then rent out space
uh throughout the year and kind of use
the the income from the community space
to fund the the events uh but that's
very early stages of
thinking so for the main funding source
for sh we uh it's mainly form the
donation for both for last year and this
year for last year uh 100% of them F
donation and for this year
60% of f donation and we got the
donation Min from the uh Asia
communities and ogs because they want to
help more Asia developers to grow that's
why we got the main dones from them uh
but it's also a very for the long-term
perspective there are lot lots of
problem we need to solve the first the
fun we need to get the sustainable no
matter is a cash flow or some bsiness to
get to help to make it more sustainable
yeah yeah this is a big one so
sustainability is difficult for this the
way we have approached it is um oh and
also for context when we say the
quadratic funding round what that
means like specifically is that um
primarily vitalic put up a pot of
funding to say hey I want to see this
movement become a thing in the world and
we use quadratic funding as a way to
allocate that um Capital within the
ecosystem and and kind of encourage new
folks to join so to just so people
understand it's essentially um a couple
of individuals who are excited about
this movement who want to bootstrap it
into existence but for vitalic and for
others uh who are funding these things
it's very important that sustainability
is eventually reached and this can't
just be something that relies on high
net worth individuals or or you know um
foundations forever so the way we've
approached it is um are very grateful to
those sources that helped us start and
then we have broken even on every event
that we've done but it takes an insane
amount of work to be able to do that
this time around we
um we so okay Edge city is a foundation
it's a 501c3 nonprofit we're not trying
to make money on the events so basically
we take whatever the event costs and
then we divide that by the ticket price
and then for anything where we need to
cover we look for Partnerships where it
makes sense for organizations and
institutions that want to have a
presence in some capacity they want to
support us but really we wanted to be
like an active uh participatory
partnership so they actually want to run
an experiment on the ground um as an
example the metamask team really wanted
to run an experiment at Edge City Lana
and we asked for a contribution there
they bought a bunch of tiet tickets at
full price Etc we the reason those
things are those kinds of relationships
are important is because for a lot of
people I think maybe 20 to 30% of our
tickets are very heavily subsidized
because you know obviously not everyone
can afford to buy a ticket let alone
come to Thailand and there are a lot of
people who we want to make sure they
have that opportunity um yeah that's
that's how we think about it yeah thank
you I think fairly similar with Georgia
what we did was we took what is the cost
what are the expenses and then divide
that um down to figure out what would
ticket prices be we also only had these
um rounds that t that everybody
mentioned um that helped us with the
down payment and so that's probably
another piece if you want to start your
own one of the hardest lifts if you're
not going to have investment or sponsors
to begin with and you want to just have
the participants all share the costs is
how are you going to have enough for a
Down payment so that's a piece that we
wouldn't have solved if it didn't if we
there wasn't a donation round like that
um then so one one thing on that the the
actual I should have mentioned this the
thing that we developed with metamask
was a tool to help us solve this exact
issue it's called Propel and we did it
in a small scale where basically if you
have an event that you need some upfront
money for let's say you want to go see
the elephants and it costs $100 to rent
the bus to do that you you you let
people pledge towards that event and if
you hit a certain threshold of people
who want to do it then the money
transfers to the organizer and it does
that know complete crypto rails
obviously very seamless way and you
could imagine like that's a really good
thing to have on the ground but then you
could imagine that at a higher scale
where you know we say hey we really want
to do a pop-up City in um in Georgia or
wherever you know who's interested and
then if 300 people people put down a
deposit of 500 usdc or something then it
auto unlocks for the organizer and they
can actually start to use that money as
like working capital ahead of time
that's fantastic yeah during the Z
Georgia hackathon also a couple people
who may be here Tred to tackle this by
creating some type of way of you know
showing that you intend before you go I
think that is one of the I think many
many this is I'm not the first to say
this many people have been sharing that
one of the unique selling point unique
value ads of these pop-up cities that
are fairly web 3 and Builder focus is
that they are incubating produ products
or projects that are powering these
cities and actually tackling the exact
problems that we're mentioning so all
that being said I'm I think we could
talk a little bit about what is behind
the scenes what are some things that
participants may not be aware of but if
they want to start their own they should
re keep in mind and try to at least be
prepared
for you could also touch on biggest
challenges well part of it because maybe
participants aren't as aware of those as
well to go for someone earlier I think
it was Charlie Fisher he was saying it's
kind of you're like a duck where you're
like gently floating through but
underneath the surface your legs are
just going like crazy and that's exactly
how it feels where especially this past
event everyone's like oh man you seem so
chill I'm like yeah front of house is
great everyone's having a good time back
of house is like intense you know
there's a lot going on um biggest
challenges I mean like ahead of time
finding the venues huge finding the
right location the right Partners
hardest thing um figuring out how you're
going to do tickets what is your
application process going to be like how
strict are you going to be you know who
do you how do you Market this how do you
who who's like the people you want to
attract um that's you know obviously
huge issues on the ground just creating
structures that can be copied and taken
by people like figure out ways to
empower people to create their own
experience for others is critical
because um you I don't think you should
aim to kind of centrally plan the whole
thing that it just becomes a conference
so you want people engaged but you need
the right structure for that so we've
created a Playbook it's it's live we're
going to update it based on the
learnings we have here we're open
sourcing all of our learnings so try to
encourage more people to to try stuff
like this um but yeah there some yes
same as as and uh I think the um before
the event start uh for we the last for
about six weeks and before the event
start there is a work at least two
months you need to prepare for
yeah that's say it's a lot of work need
to do before the event start and for at
the time that event starts there are
also lots of things need to do keep
going if because you know each week we
have the agenda structure for it and
each week we have the lecture hall
something like that you need to prepare
each week and during the last six weeks
sometimes I was struggle and outside
because you just finish one week
preparing and you need to prepare for
the next week next two weeks next three
weeks that's oh that's so terrible yeah
that's why there lots of things need to
do and if you really want to start your
own pup status you need to prepare for
it be careful with
housing booking housing can be very
difficult and logistically intensive so
if you're going to take on housing start
early because that's yeah that's very
difficult and get a deposit because that
can also be a big obstacle um
um what else I think adaptability as an
organizer you know if somebody comes to
you with an idea it's kind of
willingness to get out of the way and
say yes that's a great idea run with it
even if you know it wasn't planned uh
you know let let people in the community
experiment so like one of our biggest
Community Partnership uh events was this
business registration that we did with
Cube Zanzibar and we organized it maybe
3 days before the event actually
happened and we had government officials
300 entrepreneurs come through and that
wouldn't have happened if you know
ficker one of the community members
hadn't just said can I do this and we
just gave her the space and got out of
her way um so
keeping being being open as an organizer
I think is also very important you
talked about the balance between bottom
up and and top- down programming and
it's a very delicate uh balance to
strike but also as an organizer like
trying to tap into what the community
interested in where they're going so at
zanzu we noticed that people love
Community dinners and in the budget we
originally didn't have anything for
Community dinners but people were
gathering in uh the main event space
kind of co-working space on the Pavilion
rooftop uh playing board games just
hanging out so you know if we just throw
$200 in and provide food for everyone it
it turns it into a whole evening right
so trying to be adaptable and and move
into where the community is going and
and kind of contribute to to that
camaraderie and growth because it's very
difficult to cultivate Community as I'm
sure everyone up here knows um so yeah
just kind of keeping an open mind with
with where the group uh decides to take
take the experiment and also one advice
for people who want to organize their
own popups it's also the what we learned
from zalo is that don't handle the
accommodation by yourself
yeah it's yeah it's very important to uh
to uh collaborate with loal hotel or
some someone to handle the hotel or
accommodation it's very important
because lots of things if you handle the
accommodation by yourself lots of things
need to be done
here absolutely agree with all of the
points that you guys said just a couple
that I'll quickly add um privacy and
security is something that you may want
to consider depending on the where
you're going to be the target group Etc
um as I mentioned we went on the Very
extreme side of privacy in security
which also caus various friction but you
want to identify what your group will
need what you need what the geographic
context is as well and so related also
deciding the text stack relate that will
help with what your needs are we talked
about different tools that maybe can
help with some of our pain points those
are still being our being built I know
have a few that are trying to tackle
accommodation because that is the
biggest headache for anyone that tries
to organize that many people um or from
an example from Georgia is we chose not
to use telegram um for a few reasons and
so we were trying to use status um up
until just a week a week before and we
almost almost going to future future
projects we will but we had to switch to
another one for for various reasons what
did you use we ended up using element um
a matrix server with element of UI but
maybe next time status for sure we we
could actually nerd out on this maybe
not right now but like one of the
biggest issues we have is what bloody
messaging platform do we use like if at
all the telegram just gets so insanely
busy and I mean we and also obviously
privacy concerns we'd love to use signal
but there's just ux issues and you it's
really hard to figure this out when you
go above a certain number of people
so bullish on status um let's our final
question before we then open it up for
audience Q&A is what comes next what are
you doing personally next what's your
project yeah what's does the future
hold okay um we didn't figure out which
city we the next Shah is but the we plan
for about the next during sometime
between next August to November the next
sh will going to happen but we didn't
figure out the which city or the
location yet and we are still and also
what is n is very important is that we
trying to figure out ways that make it
more sustainable and this is a very
important question noway well focusing
on and trying to figure out
way so we are in the early stages of
planning for zenzal 2 it will be June
20th to July 18th around those States I
might be mixing them up um but it'll be
about Midsummer um I mentioned that
we're this year we're focused especially
on Talent getting the right people in uh
governance so we have this kind of not
Playdoh City but we have a Sandbox in
and fumba town so we're excited to
partner with the private developer and
really test out some IRL governance
projects uh culture and education so I
think Bernardo is a zandu he's back
there um he hosted a session last year
on identify fraudulent crypto projects
blockchain and crypto can solve serious
problems in East Africa with Banking and
access to stable currencies but it can
be difficult to spot uh real and
fraudulent projects so kind of doubling
down on the education component as well
uh with the overarching vision of
helping to incubate a growth ecosystem
in in Zanzibar so that's what we're
excited to to do and and looking forward
to zanel
too um so we have a pretty full road map
for next next year we'll probably do
three of the kind of big uh villages
that we're used to doing and um most
likely three smaller experiences we'll
announce this all before the end of the
year but we will be back in California
for Edge Esmeralda 2025 there's now a
permanent New Town being built there
called Esmeralda and Our intention is to
keep doing this event every year to keep
bringing more and more energy to that
project we are um going to be working
with them very closely it's a very
exciting thing that's happening there so
I'm I'm excited um the two other ones
we'll share more detail about soon but
very very exciting um things coming and
I think more conceptually the the the
thing that we're thinking about is kind
of what I said at the start of how do we
actually create meaningful things that
come out of these environments so that
we're not just doing the events to do
the events and to have a good time to
you know kind of gather I think if if
there is a if there is a failure mode of
um this whole pop-up City movement it's
that I think 5 10 years from now we
don't want to look back and be like oh
man that was such a good time it's such
a fun time in Thailand I genuinely
believe and that's great right it's not
a failure but it's a failure towards the
potential of what this could be I think
because I genuinely think that these
environments are new surface area for
new types of of ideas for how to live
how to build community how to actually
create the infrastructure for you know
this whole new world and I think that
those ideas are currently
percolating in in the community there's
incredible things being built at least I
can I could speak on on our end some of
the things that the hackathon some of
the things that the residencies we had a
lot of them are now being used at Devcon
um there's a lot of big booths now that
are going to be at the main um at the
main event look out for the cursive one
on programmable cryptography it's going
to be awesome so having teams like that
where I can clearly see like wow this
could be world changing and it's being
developed right now in these
environments and it potentially could
only be developed in popup cities like
these that's what I think we need we
need kind of like the killer app that
people can point at and be like wow that
could not have been developed in the
private Market or in the government or
in a think tank it had to come from this
kind of environment so that's
that's I don't in my conceptual Ro map
at
least thank you yeah and for Zo village
where there are a number of zoo
villagers or people that were at the zoo
Village Georgia experiment that are now
planning and organizing their own um
popups in the coming months and years
from I mean both Vitalia Zug happening
right at the start of next year there's
a new one brewing in Detroit I'm not
sure how much I can say um he's here um
there's Zu land in May there's a handful
happening um are being planned in Japan
in the fall and there's a lot happening
in Argentina as well those are some
there so at least my co-initiator Burns
and I we have been talking with a number
of different people that are organizing
them to support advise help as we can
and that post I mentioned that we wrote
on less wrong one of the only bit of
advertising that we did it was called or
we we described what we call the
directional protocol for the Zulu
movement as we understood it um and so
one of the things because right now
personally I'm focusing a lot more on
the technical side and software we're
exploring how we could potentially turn
that into something that's actually like
a protocol so any popup Village could
say yes we sign on to I think it's truth
and truthfulness as the at first and
trust and trustworthiness as the second
DC techno optimism but essentially if
you want to um adopt those to then be a
zoo Village or so but that's still I
heard earlier today a con what was it
concept of a plan I think from your your
talk I think that that's where we are so
we have that directional protocol and
we're trying to see could that be put
into technology and then otherwise
supporting the really amazing popups
that are happening so that's just about
time I don't know
if yeah let's go ahead and open up
questions for the
audience are there any questions for any
of us yeah there's a microphone in the
center you can come and thank you hi my
name is ala and you mentioned a little
bit about having the balance between top
down and bottom up governance so I'm
curious to know how do you
balance identifying patterns on realtime
Trends to adapt to needs from the people
that you didn't anticipate coming and
then at the end of the pop-up cities
when they are wrapped up how do you
collect feedback in order to make sure
that when you do it next time you're
Gathering those learnings and improving
the whole experience every time you go
into a new city or if you come back to
the same place so basically I'm like
curious to know how do you do it in real
time and react quickly and then how do
you do it like at the end of
it for zalo it might have been a bit
easier because we had a fairly small
full-time uh residency um being at Edge
and seeing how you guys handle feedback
I I had a
couple conversations with Cheyenne and
she was really thoughtful about this so
I know you guys are are thinking about
it a lot
um yeah so I guess I'll yeah I mean we
could do it a lot better I think but we
the way we structure it now is we do
weekly assemblies or town halls um where
and then we have a constant feedback
form that's always being shared the QR
code is always there and we're really
encouraging people to to tell us what
can improve it so to your point for the
little things like hey the coffee is
cold in the morning that's something we
can fix straight away for the bigger
things we we note it down and we have
just a lot of working sessions on it and
some things we do it it meaningfully
changes our strategic directions
actually sometimes one example is we ran
an experiment of residencies this time
around which was a complete you know we
kind of just made it up but we had three
residencies each one had about 15 to 20
people they were focused that had their
own tracks and and programming going on
but then they were also very much part
of the the city and they had weekly demo
days and things like that um the
feedback was incredible like the people
in it had an amazing time other folks
maybe the the only thing we heard was
like oh I wish I'd heard about that
sooner I would have participated so
that's something that's much kind of
bigger and that will now inform our
thinking going
forward I think sorry just to add one
more thing I I think the uh Town Halls
like Zulu has had a lot of town halls we
had one at the end of zenzal to get
feedback Edge has had a lot of them um
those are really important just giving
people a platform to voice voice their
ideas what they like what they don't
like um but also encouraging people to
take ownership over projects like if
they come to you and say I want to see X
happen then say that's awesome that's a
great idea do it like it's a co-created
thing go for it like that's that'd be
awesome I think everyone would would Ben
benefit from that so I think pushing you
know organizational power down as much
as you can and saying this is this is an
open space for everyone to contribute is
is one way to kind of uh you know give
space for the community to self-correct
or to to to go certain directions and
adapt yeah and adwi thing for last last
last sway that after um last year Shang
some media platform collect all the
reden Story the all the reden read their
own memories during the Shah W which is
very important because each of the
participant participant in different
activities that's why Shah is just not
only focusing on what is the story that
the culture contributor to it's a
collection of the old members and create
the sh with match together yeah that's
it vable and I think maybe this year in
chimi we could access some media
platform to do it together because what
in chimi is so different is that there
are lots of popup cities and each
members have their own memory for this
Chim palago yeah yeah of off the events
basis point uh one thing that I thought
was really helpful is a lot of us use
social layer to uh do the the bottom up
coordination so people can just add
their own uh events straight into the
calendar and people can you know click
in but they also like you can get all of
the data and see how people use the
spaces because as an organizer right
your main job is to set the artifactual
structure within which the community
grows so if you can see okay what
infrastructure is being used most
heavily then that can inform how you
prepare the event spaces in the next
event um so it's kind of this background
data and you know after the event taking
stock of how people use the space and
and what the expectations are for the
next year is is really important the
only thing I'll add um is I think it's
really important to have a truly
Anonymous PL like place that people can
give feedback we saw that already in zuc
connnect and we had one in Zu Village
Georgia and I think zui had a little bit
of experiments with it but I think in
any type of collective action or let
alone governments there should be a
place where people where speech is
completely free and Anonymous you cannot
trace it to anybody that's where ZK can
come in that we've been experimenting in
our spaces um yeah so making sure that
there's a place where people know that
they can't be prosecuted for what
they're saying and then the tradition I
think I agreed looking at the data of
how the platforms are being used as well
as traditional surveys we did have an
anonymous but also a survey that people
could fill out so we could get a little
bit more
feedback I think that's all the time we
have well thank you all so much thank
you all for joining us thank you again
logos thank you so much thank you thank
you so much
[Music]